françois hollande nicolas sarkozy sait
je ne t'aime pas moi non plus les deux
rivaux historiques sont les personnages
principaux du film d'anne fontaine
président raconte une alliance
improbable entre françois hollande joué
par grégory gadebois et nicolas sarkozy
campé par jean dujardin on commence à
traire à partie voilà la france pour
toujours présent bonjour bonjour à tous
on fait la campagne et je suis est en
effet lui voir les deux ex présidents
reformer un parti politique sous le ton
de la comédie peut faire sourire car oui
en dehors des caméras
les hommes ne sont pas vraiment à nice
ils ont le même âge la même ascension
politique et cela fait plus de trente
ans qu'ils s'envoient des piques
interposés il a de l'ambition il a même
de l'appétit je suis pas sûr qu'il sache
toujours cette ambition le guide
et si en matière alimentaire il a
toujours le nez fin l'immigration
l'éducation ou la laïcité sont les
thèmes sur lesquels ils se sont le plus
affrontés comme en 2003 sur le voile à
l'école
avec cette loi vous communautariser les
gens parce que vous dirai aux français
dont les familles croient qu'ils n'ont
plus leur place dans l'école de la
république
à chacun son école en fonction de sa
communauté
la loi qui exclura les petites parce
qu'elle croit les poussera dans des
écoles confessionnelles musulmane où le
voile ne sera pas une possibilité mais
une obligation
une seule fois les deux hommes
s'affichent côte à côte nous sommes en
2005 pour la campagne du référendum sur
la constitution européenne
tous les deux font la une de paris match
et c'est le socialiste
qui en paie les frais cette photo devait
installer son image de présidentiable
pour françois hollande elle est devenue
un boulet la voilà donc détourné par le
groupe attache les altermondialistes en
ont fait une affiche pour le nom déjà
diffusé sur internet une fois président
de la république nicolas sarkozy prend
de haut son rival qui ne se laisse pas
faire pour nicolas sarkozy président et
s'est parlé et convenons qu'il préside
beaucoup puisqu'il parle beaucoup
françois hollande ira encore plus loin
en 2012 lors de la passation pouvoir le
nouveau président ne raconte pas nicolas
sarkozy et son épouse avant d'en
remettre une bûche au salon de
l'agriculture
mais c'est nicolas sarkozy qui a le
dernier mot en 2015 lorsque françois
hollande toujours président est au plus
bas
il fut un temps où santini disait qu'à
force de chuter dans les sondages
j'avais fini par trouver du pétrole mais
lui françois hollande
il est au niveau du gaz de schiste
beaucoup plus bas depuis silence radio
les deux éternels ennemis ne
s'affrontent plus en public
[Musique]